a really big deal was made by Trump
supporters including the queen of the
birther movement orly taitz a few days
ago that finally at least one poll
showed that Donald Trump was ahead of
Hillary Clinton I looked into that pole
it's the LA Times USC tracking poll
which just happens to be a poll that
tracks about 3,000 eligible voters daily
asking them who they support and how
likely they are to vote it is the only
poll that for two days showed trump
ahead from like the last three weeks and
even that pole has already turned to
saying that Hillary Clinton is ahead
birther queen orly taitz has stopped
emailing me since that number has
changed here's the big picture right now
in two-way polls and we will start by
showing you these in two-way polls
Hillary Clinton is leading Donald Trump
in 25 of the last 25 polls now let me do
some math 25 / 25 2/2 is one carries
your that's one hundred percent of
recent polls in one hundred percent of
the last 25 polls as you can see here
Hillary Clinton is ahead of Donald Trump
now some people will hear me say this
they will say David uh you're not
including libertarian Gary Johnson or
green party candidate Jill Stein in the
polling and you should and I will that
is an understandable and reasonable
concern if we look at recent four-way
polling Hillary Clinton is leading 23 of
the most recent 23 polls number 24 in
terms of reverse chronological order has
her tied yes Hillary Clinton's average
lead is slightly lower when Jill Stein
and Gary Johnson are included four point
three percent uh I'm the four-way polls
five point nine percent in the two-way
polls but it is still remaining a very
one-sided race nate silver's
fivethirtyeight.com assesses the
probability that one or another
candidate will win here is how he
currently has it eighty-five percent
chance that Hillary Clinton will win
this election fifteen percent chance
that Donald Trump will win this election
look at the bottom of this image if
you're looking with me statistically
speaking
estimating Hillary Clinton's electoral
vote total around 350 4 and Trump's in
the 180s which would be needless to say
an embarrassing and historic defeat
popular vote estimating somewhere in the
range of 48 to 41 in favor of Hillary
Clinton and lastly electoral dash vote
dot-com updates a map based on
state-by-state polling every day that
estimates 343 delegates for Hillary
Clinton 195 for Donald Trump very
similar numbers Louis between the
electoral vote dot-com analysis and the
fivethirtyeight.com analysis uh we are
starting to run out of time it is it
that this is something where if the
numbers don't change soon and I don't
know if a major bombshell about Hillary
Clinton would change numbers I don't
know if a some kind of national security
or terrorism crisis would hurt Hillary
Clinton we've said because of the
particularly rash and harebrained nature
of Donald Trump and because of the more
neoconservative foreign policy ideas of
Hillary Clinton the standard paradigm
where terrorist attacks close to an
election help the Republican may not
actually hold true in this particular
election if something doesn't change
soon Hillary Clinton is going to win by
a lot on november eighth mm-hmm right
now the Republican counter to this is
that these polls just aren't accurate uh
and so you're right what possible
massive groundbreaking catastrophic
thing could happen to Hillary Clinton
yeah um I I don't think there is one she
just she really doesn't need to do much
more at this point she's got it gamefly
is sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low use price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com
TDPS the games are shipped directly to
you with return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30-day trial for the david pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to gamefly offer.com slash TDP s